- I know what you're thinking.
In Defense of Auto-Tune,
what is there to defend?
Sure, we may think we
know how Auto-Tune works,
and it's practically an
industry staple these days,
but there's more to it
than making someone sound like a robot.
- So you're singing over a piano sample
I recorded in F sharp minor.
- Okay.
- And so once you sing, we'll
have your vocals preserved,
there's no Auto-Tune running through it,
and then I'll apply the
Auto-Tune and we'll see,
compare how it sounds.
I am Elijah Fox, I am a pianist,
producer, and songwriter.
I'm based in Los Angeles right now.
Me and Linda both met
at Oberlin Conservatory.
- Yes.
- Where we graduated in 2017.
♪ Na na na na na na ♪
- [Narrator] The use of
Auto-Tune has become so common
since it launched in the late '90s,
that it's easy to forget that it caught
so much flack throughout the 2000s.
Many were concerned that it
was making music inauthentic.
- In this video, we're gonna
talk about how Auto-Tune
became the in-demand tool
for recording studios,
helped artists find their artistic selves,
and evolved popular music.
And be sure to stay for the end
where we will create an
original track using Auto-Tune.
This is "In Defense of Auto-Tune."
♪ Like summer in the fall ♪
♪ I shouldn't have cared at all ♪
- Auto-Tune was first released in 1997,
but let's first set the stage
for pop music at that time.
(upbeat music)
Let's go back to the 1980s,
the decade that saw an
increase in recording studios
using digital recording and
non-traditional instruments
like drum machines and synthesizers,
and let's not forget the birth of MTV.
- [Narrator] All of these
things helped to transform
pop music into what we know it as today.
With artists like
Madonna, Whitney Houston,
Michael Jackson, and Prince
serving as inspiration for future stars.
- Pop stars were becoming larger than life
and their performances
had to reflect that.
Choreographed dance
routines, wardrobe changes.
Pop artists were now expected
to put on full productions
with their music.
So lip syncing became more
common in arena concerts
in the late '80s and onward.
- Well girl, you know it's True,
it can only mean Milli Vanilli.
- This all came to ahead in 1989
when Milli Vanilli were
performing their hit single
"Girl You Know It's True" live
and the chorus of the
track kept repeating.
♪ Girl you know it's ♪
- The Milli Vanilli controversy,
as well as general pushback
against artists lip syncing
during live performances
played a part in why Auto-Tune
wasn't widely promoted
when it first came out.
Something its own inventor noticed, too,
sharing in a 2016 article,
"Studios weren't going
out and advertising,
'Hey, we got Auto-Tune!'
Back then, the public
was weary of the idea
of fake or affected music.
What they don't understand is
that the method used before,
doing hundreds of takes
and splicing them together,
was its own form of
artificial pitch correction."
Those are the words of Andy Hildebrand,
an engineer, a mathematician,
a former flute player,
and of course, the man behind Auto-Tune.
- [Narrator] Launched in September, 1997,
Auto-Tune was the result of Hildebrand
fusing math with music,
with some inspiration from a colleague
who joked about wanting a
device to help her sing in tune.
- What Auto-Tune does is
it automatically corrects
the note you're singing
towards the closest version of that note
that's tuned to A440 or standard tuning.
So that means if you sing a
note that's close to a D sharp,
it's gonna move it down to a D sharp
'cause that's in that key.
But if you sing a note that's in-between,
it's gonna have to pick
whatever you were closest to
and then auto-tune it to
the notes from that scale.
- Cher's "Believe" is the song
that made Auto-Tune known
throughout the world,
but not for the pitch correcting
reason it was made for.
Notice how Cher's voice
sounds inhuman, robotic-like.
♪ Ooh, do you believe in life after love ♪
- This is because of Auto-Tune's
retune speed feature.
Can you explain what the
retune speed function is
and what it does?
- Definitely.
Retune speed is basically on
the interface of the Auto-Tune,
there's a Retune button,
which is basically telling
the software how fast you
want the notes to transition
while it's kind of reading your vocals.
So to put that kind of more easier,
it's just like you can
go from a retune speed,
which is really low,
which is literally zero.
Or you can go to a higher
retune speed of 50, 70,
where you probably wouldn't
even detect it at all.
- [Elijah] This is the
vocal completely dry.
♪ Ooh, na na na na na na ♪
- [Elijah] So I'll put an Auto-Tune.
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
- [Elijah] And let's see what it does.
Here we go.
♪ It rains, it rains so rarely here ♪
- So it sounds absolutely terrible
because we haven't set the key yet.
So here I'm gonna go F sharp, scale minor,
then I'm gonna put it so that
the retune speed is slow.
So this will be the most realistic.
And then I'm gonna set
humanize to the max.
So now we've got
♪ Ooh na na na na na ♪
- [Elijah] And you can see
the notes that Linda's singing
are showing up here.
♪ It rains, it rains ♪
- [Elijah] So if I do retune
speed fast, it's that classic.
♪ But in my mind the
clouds don't ever clear ♪
- Auto-Tune could not only
be used to correct notes.
It could also be used as a creative tool
to change one's voice entirely.
But the use of Auto-Tune
wasn't welcomed by all.
- At what point did you see
that Auto-Tune was like, oh,
this is tight, this is cool.
Like who was the artist
that turned it on for you?
- Well, definitely I'm not gonna lie,
the first artist that
really turned it on for me
was back in the day watching
"106 & Park", T-Pain.
As soon as his music came on,
it just was something totally...
At least for people of my
age and it was pretty new.
♪ I like the bartender ♪
♪ Yeah, if you're lookin' for me ♪
- From the mid to late 2000s,
T-Pain became synonymous with Auto-Tune.
He popularized the effect in R&B and Rap,
giving way to hit singles
like Lil Wayne's "Lollipop"
and Kanye West's "808s
& Heartbreak" album.
♪ How could you be so heartless ♪
- Auto-Tune became more well-known
for distorting vocals than fixing them.
With auto-tuned hits like Black
Eyed Peas' "Boom Boom Pow"
and Kesha's "Tik Tok"
being some of the decade's biggest songs.
♪ Tick-tock on the clock ♪
♪ But the party don't stop, no ♪
- Because of this, the
tool became a target
by those who thought it
was making music artificial
and fake, like the lip-sync
debacle of the 90s,
Auto-Tune was facing a similar moment.
- Jay Z called for Auto-Tune's death
on his 2009 song, "D.O.A."
"Death of Auto-Tune,"
where he condemned the
overuse of the effect.
♪ This is anti auto-tune,
death of the ring-tone ♪
♪ This ain't for iTunes ♪
- Although Jay clarified
that the song wasn't directed
at T-Pain, West, or Wayne,
who we all saw as good
examples of using Auto-Tune,
T-Pain took it personally.
In an interview with Netflix,
T-Pain recounts a time where Usher
told him that he ruined music.
- [Narrator] That is the very moment,
and I don't even think I
realized this for a long time,
but that's the very moment
that started a four-year
depression for me."
- [Caller] Hey man, look
you're well missed, man.
I wish you would have never disappeared.
You disappeared when Jay Z
came out with damn record.
I wish you would've stayed,
you made good quality music.
- Well, the flack directed
at Auto-Tune and T-Pain
didn't age well.
For starters, the artist is
actually a very good singer
as he showcased in his
2014 Tiny Desk performance.
♪ Yeah, ooh ooh ohh, ooh ooh ♪
♪ We in the bed like ♪
♪ Na na na na na na na ♪
- And what you used is
not what Roger used.
- No, Roger used a vocoder.
- What's that?
- Roger used a vocoder.
- Vocoders use synthesizers
to alter a singer's voice
and musicians have been
using them since the 1950s.
Listen to Herbie Hancock use a vocoder
in the 1978 track "I Thought It Was You."
♪ Thought it was you ♪
♪ I thought it was you ♪
- Auto-Tune isn't just a
tool for pitch correcting,
but a spiritual successor
to previous inventions
used for vocal experimentation.
Auto-Tune and similar
products like Melodyne
are still being used for pitch correcting
and vocal experimentation.
Some producers even use them in tandem.
- Can you tell us the difference
between Auto-Tune and Melodyne
and like how you would use.
- Yeah.
So what Melodyne does is
it doesn't actually correct
any of the notes, but
it shows you how many
since you were sharp
or flat for each note,
and then lets you adjust.
So, with Melodyne, you can
kind of go halfway sort of,
but Auto-Tune is just
gonna directly tune it
to standard tuning.
(device beeping)
- Linda, what's up, how you doing?
- Good, it's good to see you.
- Yes, always great seeing you.
So Auto-Tune (imitates Auto-Tune)
the effect.
- Yeah, yeah! (laughs)
- I was always doing
that when I was a kid,
so I'm glad that we
spent some time with it.
- Yeah, me too.
- How much experience do
you have with Auto-Tune?
- To be honest, I always
knew that it was like
different than what the general
public perceived it to be.
And I think that's kind of
like, you know, for a long time,
the music industry was hiding the fact
that people even used Auto-Tune.
I think a lot of people
have a misconception
about like how vocalists use their voices
and about what Auto-Tune
necessarily means.
Like they think of it as like
slap the Auto-Tune filter
over everything you sing, and
that's Auto-Tune, you know?
And it's a lot more nuanced than that.
I think sometimes people will watch
these like live performances
and they'll be like,
see, this person doesn't
need any Auto-Tune,
and it's like, that mic was auto-tuned.
- People have no idea like
how much it's actually used
in the industry.
- In LA, for every session that I was in,
the mic automatically had Auto-Tune on it,
and I had never experienced that, yeah.
- So now it's time to apply
our own flavor to Auto-Tune,
and make an original
song using the effect.
I think I'm ready to hear this track.
- [Linda] Yes, okay.
- Here goes nothing.
♪ It rains, it rains so rarely here ♪
♪ But in my mind ♪
- I'm thinking about what
I could do with this.
What I would do with it?
A boom-bap kind of thing,
it feels too forceful.
I'm thinking like sparse samps.
- Mm-hm.
- You know what I'm saying?
- Like little brushes.
- Ah! I need that. (laughs)
- [Linda] That's what I was thinking.
- I need that!
No, let's do it!
♪ It rains, it rains so rarely here ♪
♪ But in my mind the
clouds don't ever clear ♪
♪ Without a smile, I am so out of place ♪
♪ So I can try to put one on my face ♪
♪ It feels like summer in the fall ♪
♪ I shouldn't have cared at all ♪
- Hmm.
Yes, yes.
Fire, yes.
(gentle music)